[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Welcome, everyone.
Try to start on time.
Are there any questions
from last time?
OK, we'll take a look
at the class syllabus.
We did a theory lecture
on Walrasian equilibria
and 2x2x2 trade models
in theory, last class.
Today, we're going
to begin the first
of two applications of that.
You can see, in fact, on
the reading list the papers
for today, which includes this
thing with my Thai colleague,
Archawa, which is taking
the theory model back
to the Thai applications.
And there's an additional
stared reading here,
Dawkins, which is
calibration, which
we have done before with the
medieval villages and dynamics.
And today, we're
going to do it again.
But that start reading
does not appear anywhere,
particularly in the lectures.
But still, there aren't
a lot of new theorems
and stuff in the lecture
today, mostly concepts.
So I think you can get some time
to look at the Dawkins starred
article.
And on the class schedule--
so after the trade lecture
application today and the one
next Thursday.
And then the following
week, on Tuesday,
I'll conduct with you a review
session of the material covered
in the last 1/3 of the class.
So that's the way
the schedule looks.
Again, let me ask if
there are questions.
Otherwise, I'm going to
turn to the study guide
and, in particular, the material
from last time lecture 13.
So the first review
question was, in addition
to reviewing what it takes
in general equilibrium terms
to describe an economy,
what additional features do
we need to put in there to
describe a private ownership
economy?
And let me see if--
Dixon, do you want to
take a stab at that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so for general
equilibrium [INAUDIBLE]
we need like the consumers'
like preferences and consumption
set, the firm technology, which
is the production set, and then
economy resources,
which is endowment.
But additionally, for
the private ownership,
each consumer has
their own endowment.
And also, each consumer has a
complete ownership of the firm.
So the firm is made out
of consumer ownership.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Good, OK.
Yeah, each consumer
has shares in firms.
So those were the
theta ij parameters.
So if there are profits, as in
decreasing returns to scale,
those profits get distributed
back to households.
So they own the
returns on the firm.
So that's a great answer.
Thank you so much.
What is the potential difference
between a Walrasian equilibrium
and a price equilibrium
with transfers?
Maria Sofia, do you
want to try that one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so with
the price equilibrium
with transfers,
we're looking to see
if there exists some
assignment of wealth levels
such that the economy will
satisfy a set of constraints.
But in general, a
Walrasian equilibrium
is a type of price
equilibrium with transfers,
except we have the condition
that the wealth is equal to--
I think it's the
price times the wealth
plus the sum of the
profits over the shares
that the consumer has
in various companies.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yes, that's right.
So the Walrasian
equilibrium works off
of this private
ownership economy.
So we have the valuation of
the household's endowment
plus the valuation
of the profits
that the household
has a claim to.
And that is a wealth object.
So technically, it looks
like a price equilibrium
with transfers,
meaning that if we
assign that particular
wealth, we're
going to have an equilibrium.
The more general idea
behind the price equilibrium
with transfers, though,
including the transfers part,
is that the wealth assignments
that we give to households
may be greater or less than the
valuation of the wealth they
would have if we had restricted
ourselves to private ownership.
So what I didn't, I guess,
emphasize very much is
there are going to be
two welfare theorems
that we will study in detail.
One is that the Walrasian
equilibrium is pareto optimal.
And for that part, we need
private ownership only.
And the second is going to
be that any pareto optimal
allocation can be achieved with
the suitable redistribution
of wealth.
And that's the part
where we're going
to need this more general
concept of price equilibrium
with transfers.
The ordering of the class was
to introduce this Walrasian
equilibrium notion, not dwell
on the optimality of it,
but rather get into some
applications and then.
In a couple of weeks, we'll be
back to those welfare theorems
and when they are true
and when they can fail.
So that's the
ordering of the class.
And we got into the 2x2x2.
All of this stuff
at the beginning
is kind of a review
of the notation, where
we have minimizing the cost
of achieving a unit output,
given the vector
of factor prices w.
And we had the
cost-minimizing input values.
And at the end of all that, I
finally got around to asking,
define what it means for
the production of good 1
to be relatively more
intensive in factor 1
than the production of good 2.
So [INAUDIBLE] see
if we can get some--
how about a volunteer
for that one?
AUDIENCE: I can take this one.
Yeah, so this means that for
producing a unit of good 1
versus a unit of good 2, you
need the ratio of factor 1
to factor 2 that's used to
produce one unit of good 1
is greater than the
ratio of factor 1
to factor 2 in producing
a unit of good 2.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Excellent.
Perfect answer.
And then implicit, let
me just add a little bit
editorial, which is, it's
defined over the whole domain.
So whatever those factor
prices are, w1 in w2,
it remains true that good one
uses relatively more factor
1 than factor 2 and vice versa.
So it's a statement
about the whole--
and we used that in
the analysis in class,
when we were looking
at the cost curves
and what would happen
if input prices moved.
Can someone take a stab at
the Stolper-Samuelson theorem
for the determination of input
prices as output prices change?
AUDIENCE: I can.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
AUDIENCE: In this
theorem, we assume
that the model [INAUDIBLE] to
modify [INAUDIBLE] then when
the output price, like
the price of good 1,
increases, then the intensive
factors in producing the good 1
also increases.
And another factor,
factor 2, that
was not the intensive
factor [INAUDIBLE]
the price of this
factor world goes down.
Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
OK, that's good.
Yup.
So nominally, it's
not a statement
about international
trade, although it
is very useful in that context.
We're just basically doing some
comparative static exercises
of what would happen if these
exogenously given output
prices are changing.
What's going to happen
to input prices?
And then we did a graph.
We used those cost
curves to illustrate it.
I flagged the last
question, but I really
don't want to ask that one.
I want to ask something a
little harder to answer.
If we had two countries,
and each country had
a representative
consumer, and there
are two goods, each of which can
be produced in both countries,
and there were two
factors that can
be used in each good
in each country,
we've got a lot of
equations and unknowns.
We've got the
consumers' consumption
levels of the two
goods, the input being
used to produce outputs
of the two goods,
the outputs themselves
and the prices of each of the
two inputs in both countries,
et cetera, et cetera.
Can someone tell me how we
attack this problem in class,
in the sense of an algorithm?
We broke it into pieces.
Otherwise, it's a very
high-dimensional problem.
If you remember the ordering--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
go ahead, please.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think that the way
that we did this was
kind of inductively,
where I think that the
way that we did this was,
first, pretend,
basically, that it's just
like the original 2x2 model.
And then we solve for the
what's supposed to happen there.
And then we built in the
additional thing of--
I'm pretty sure we built in the
different endowments, I think,
was the difference in
the 2x2x2 versus the 2x2.
But we solve for
the smaller model,
and then we build it
upwards to the bigger one.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's true.
And what, in
particular, did we focus
on first in the smaller model?
AUDIENCE: I think the way that
we did this was kind of the--
I don't think I remember this.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK, anyone else
want to take an attempt at it?
This is a difficult question
to pose and hard to answer,
because it has to
do with putting
the pieces a lot of
information in the lecture
and taking a step backwards
and thinking about it globally.
OK, well, it starts with this
Stolper-Samuelson theorem.
So at this point, early
on in the lecture,
we were taking the prices of
the goods p1 and p2, as given.
We weren't trying
to solve for that.
I had not yet introduced
consumers either.
We didn't even attempt to
solve for the quantities.
We merely wanted to find
equilibrium factor prices.
So for a given country--
you could think of it that
way, a given economy--
we had the minimized cost of
producing one unit of good 1,
the minimized cost of
producing one unit of good 2.
And that's in the space
of input prices w1 and w2.
So we're looking
for an equilibrium.
Therefore, the
input prices should
be the same regardless of
whether it's good 1 or good 2.
So we looked at where
those curves crossed,
and that's the only point in the
diagram where we can both have
common input prices of the two
inputs and be on those curves,
where the curves crossed.
So that was the very,
very first part.
And then given those prices,
we moved to a different space,
which had isoquants.
So there, we have the
unit output or any output,
really, described by an
isoquant, a different isoquant
for different quantities, and
we had the inputs on the x-axis.
So there, we solved for
minimizing unit cost again,
but what's on the x and y-axis
would be the input quantities.
And we know that has to
align with the factor
prices we already solved for.
So there, we determine both
the input quantities as well as
the output quantities,
where both firm 1 and firm 2
could be in equilibrium.
And then, finally, at the
very end of the lecture,
we zeroed out to consider two
countries, not just one, each
with a consumer.
And those countries could be in
autarky or potentially trading
with one another.
Both specifications would be
legitimate general equilibrium
environments, both autarky--
each country separately
is one-- and then
we traded another,
except, obviously,
with trade, consumption
and production
do not have to be the same,
because the countries can
export one thing
and import another.
Sorry, that's a rather
long-winded summary.
But again, it's not the
easiest lecture, maybe
potentially the hardest
lecture in the whole series
of lectures.
So I thought I
would take the time
to elaborate a bit on
what we were doing.
OK, so that's the review.
And we come to applying a very
similar theory to actual data.
So this is real
and financial flows
in Thailand and an outline.
We're going to talk
about villages again,
but we're going to embed
them in the local economy
and also their relationship
to the national economy, where
we view the financial
accounts, which
you've seen once before when
we did the Bitcoin part.
We'll review them here--
balance sheets, income
statement, and cash flow--
then more general background
on these village economies
and heterogeneity within them.
Then we'll take the village
economy, as an entire economy,
and come up with GDP
and village income,
the way we come up with
national income and the National
Income and Product Accounts.
And then, finally, as
a small open economy,
we can look at flow of funds,
balance of payments, how open
or how closed is the economy.
And then we come to
this calibration part,
which I already
highlighted, with respect
to the other starred
reading, Dawkins et al.
What does it mean
to be calibrating
a model, which they often
did in the trade context,
as we do here?
And we'll look at
model-predicted data
and compare it
directly to actual data
and then look at
some counterfactuals,
like imposing tariffs
and frictions.
So last time end today, you
could think of this question
as, free trade, who are the
winners and losers, tariffs,
who are the winners and losers,
and not in the abstract,
as in last time,
but actually here,
in the context of
a calibrated model.
You'll actually see the impact
on individual people living
in these villages.
And then when we
get to the US, we'll
do it all again on Thursday,
which is a different context,
but the same kind of theory.
OK, so you've seen this before.
Let me highlight the time map.
We have these two provinces,
Chachoengsao and Lopburi
in the central area
of the country,
near, if not right
on top of, Bangkok.
And we have the other
two, Buriram and Sisaket
in the Northeast, a much more
agrarian area of the country.
This is Sisaket.
I muttered something about not
finding these monthly starred
villages, but I knew
where they were.
And now I realize it's
still very hard to read.
But these Cheerio circles
correspond to baseline survey
done in 1997.
A subset of those
villages were chosen
from '98 onward, including
the data that we're using.
In which case, it's
a monthly survey.
So the Cheerio
covers up the star
and produces these
green-like objects up here.
So that's the cluster.
So there are four
villages in Sisaket
that constitute
the monthly data.
And likewise, there are going to
be four each in the other three
provinces.
OK so let's take Lopburi over
here, and take a wage earner,
and look at this actual
household's income statement.
So you've seen version
of this before,
and I remember asking you
about it in the follow-up.
We've got revenues and costs.
In this case, this guy does
a little bit of livestock,
but mostly, it's wage labor.
And in principle, could have
had interest income, but didn't.
And on the cost side,
most of these costs
are associated with
livestock and in debt
and actually has an
interest expense,
and then does consumption and
subtracts that off of income
and has some savings.
So that's the income statement
of household A, which
we have these
kinds of statements
for roughly 800 households.
Here's what happens over time.
That labor income, which is
the dominant source of income,
falls and then gradually
increases back up again.
Other components
are largely zero,
although they
started the business
in the last year or two.
Cultivation rises
and then falls again.
So trying this, that, or
the other, but largely
labor income.
This same household
has a balance sheet,
which has liabilities
on the right-hand side
and assets on the
left-hand side.
Since those things
don't balance,
hopefully liabilities
are smaller than assets,
and the difference is net worth.
So we have liabilities and net
worth on the right-hand side
and assets on the left.
Assets consist of
financial assets like cash
and could have been a little
bit of deposits in banks.
And those are financial
assets, and then
we have real assets like
livestock and so on,
inventories, and we
have other fixed assets,
including household assets, OK?
And you're wondering
where I'm going with this.
I'm deliberately
highlighting things
that are going to
come up momentarily.
And again, the balance sheet
over time for this household,
you can see wealth
is going up, mostly
because assets are going up.
But toward the end, when
the household started
that business, they borrowed.
Liabilities went up, and net
worth actually went down.
But anyway, this is over time.
Finally, we have the
statement of cash flow,
which I highlighted when
we talked about Bitcoin.
We've got cash flow from
production and cash flow
from financing investment
and consumption,
and that produces a
measure of cash flow
from the flows,
which has to sync up
with the change in the
cash and the balance
sheet, which it
does in these data.
So next, I want to
talk about diversity
across the
households, especially
for the ones who are
actually firms, who have
decided to go into business.
The types of activities,
cultivation, farming business
like retail outlets, trucking
stuff around livestock, fish
and shrimp.
And this is like a Cobb-Douglas
production function written out
in logs.
So delta k is the intensity
of the capital good,
and delta l is the
intensity of the labor good.
And what we want to see are
those factor intensities.
So in fact, if you look,
cultivation is labor-intensive.
It will fit the
definition we reviewed
at the beginning of class.
Uses relatively more
labor than capital
because of the coefficients
delta l and delta k.
On the other extreme,
the fish and shrimp
uses almost no labor at all
and uses tons of capital.
So we've got capital and
labor-intensive activities.
We can try to make it simpler
and talk about basically
agricultural goods versus
others called manufacturing.
It really means
non-agricultural.
OK, the other thing sitting
up here is this epsilon.
This is quote, "an error
term," but it actually
contains not just noisy data,
but a measurement of talent.
So if we took the average
for a particular household i,
we took the average
of these epsilons,
they don't have to
average out to 0.
They average out to something
that is common to the sector
that household i has
engaged in, a bar,
and some other
household-specific talent
called z, OK?
So there's a sector and
household-specific talent
variable that's wrapped
up into these epsilons.
Obviously, if you're
talented, the epsilons
are going to tend to
be high, meaning output
is going to be high,
even controlling
for capital and labor.
So if you looked across
the sectors at, quote,
"sectoral productivity,"
they are pretty similar.
The highest one
here is livestock,
the lowest one is business.
Now, in terms of the
household-specific
productivities, there's a whole
cross sectional dispersion
of these zi's in each sector.
And so this sigma is a
characterization of the--
a bit like a variance
of the distribution.
The point being that each
household has a particular z
depending on the sector
in which they reside,
and they could be very talented
or not talented at all,
even though they're
engaged in that activity.
And these are
estimated in the data.
You're looking at
the actual numbers.
The other aspect of
heterogeneity here, in addition
to household talent, would be
their wealth or, specifically,
their fixed assets.
That's why I
emphasized it when we
went through the balance sheet.
And you can see the
cross-sectional distribution
in Lopburi, which
is near Bangkok,
versus the cross sectional
distribution in Buriram, which
has a lot more mass over here
to the left, meaning low assets.
So indeed, in the data,
Lopburi near Bangkok
has higher average fixed
assets than does Buriram out
in the Northeast.
But again, it is the
whole distribution.
So a given household could
have relatively little wealth
or have a lot of
wealth, even in Buriram.
This actually is consistent
with the Pauson, Townsend,
Karaivanov paper, which was
an application of mechanism
design, where we talked about
the talent of being a firm.
Theta, I think, we had it there.
And also, we talked
about assets separately.
And indeed, we talked about a
limited liability constraint,
which is coming up.
So we have this
cash thing, which,
as I was saying, from
your previous lecture,
you know cash holdings
don't behave very well.
So we just impose what
we see in the data,
that cash holdings, that
part of wealth that they're
putting into cash, is fixed.
It turns out that consumption
is related to that.
We imposed that consumption
is equal to an intercept
plus profits less
that intercept.
And gamma here has
to do with omega,
which is the fraction of
savings that put into cash.
I didn't put the algebra
in, which I probably
should have done, except
all I want to say from this
is the cash part of savings
is just fitted to the model.
It's not something we derived.
So now I want to go
back to those accounts
and show you where gross
national product comes
from, except that,
in this case, it's
going to be village-level
product and income.
And then we'll go on to flow
of funds, the balance sheet,
balance of payments, and so on.
So the top you've seen before.
That's the statement of
income, revenues less costs,
but now we start subtracting
things from both sides.
For example, to get rid of
capital gains, capital losses,
and indemnity, we
subtract them off,
and then they appear
with the opposite sign
on the left-hand side.
Likewise, we have expenses
from production, which
we subtract off of both sides.
Hence, it disappears on the
left hand side and reappears
on the right, and
it's subtracted.
So we end up with revenues
less expenses in production,
which we call output.
And on the left-hand side, we
have the disposition of output.
Output is used to pay interest.
It's used to pay
interest for capital.
Normally, you would see wages
paid to labor over here,
and I'll come back
to that momentarily.
And the residual is profits.
So all output gets paid, in the
sense of paying hired factors
or what's left over accruing
to the business owner.
So this is a classic
decomposition
of the national income accounts,
from production or from inputs.
We're really interested
in international trade,
so we're really
interested, here,
in how much is labor getting
paid, how much of the interest
being paid to capital, and so
on as a function of output,
just a bit like
the 2x2x2 lecture.
So if we're looking
at output, remember,
there are four villages
in each province that were
selected for the monthly data.
Here, you can
actually see output
going down in Chachoengsao--
wiggling, but going down--
whereas, in Buriram,
output is going up.
And these are the
other two provinces.
So another point to
make is that output
is different across
different villages,
even though they're
nearby to one another.
And also, you'll miss it
if I don't point it out,
probably, which is the
scale in the Northeast,
the maximum value is 6 and
5, whereas, in the central,
the maximum is 15 and 12.
So yeah, villages near
Bangkok have higher output
than villages in the Northeast,
but there remains heterogeneity
across the villages, and
you see the ups and downs.
The shrimp ponds got
hit with a bad shock
that we've talked about
previously in the network
lecture under risk-sharing.
So that's part of the decline
in output in Chachoengsao.
Buriram used to be
a bunch of villages.
We put rain gauges out there
to measure waterfall and so on.
And then it experienced a
boom, and those villages
were subsumed by the town.
And you can see that
expansion pretty dramatically
in this output diagram.
And as I was saying,
we can decompose output
into who gets it.
And you can see here, wages,
which is the darkest line,
is the bigger part
of the disposition
of output in Buriram.
In Sisaket, wages
are not as much--
they're not trivial
near Bangkok--
Chachoengsao and Lopburi.
Instead, we have
these two sectors,
the labor-intensive
agricultural sector
and the capital-intensive
manufacturing sector
as sometimes having
profit shares which
are higher than the wages.
Now we come to the savings
investment account.
We take the balance
sheet at a point in time,
and we take the
first difference.
So now we'll have the change in
liabilities, the change the net
worth on the right, change in
financial and real physical
assets on the left.
We now go through this thing
about subtracting items
on the left and the
right-hand side.
We leave the change in net
worth on the right-hand side
and the disposition
of that change
into an increase in
financial or real assets
or a decrease in liabilities.
So we can see they're
managing their portfolio,
in an accounting sense,
as a function of,
what do they do with savings.
And likewise, if savings are
negative because they consume
more than they earn, then they
have to draw that value out
of something or borrow.
So this is the
allocation of savings
across the four provinces.
The darkest line here is
savings, which is largely going
up, although not entirely.
Savings is going down
and Chachoengsao,
as you might have
expected, since they
got to finance those
losses, that declining
output from somewhere.
They're preserving consumption
by taking it out of savings.
Likewise, they can save
in the fixed assets,
save in the financial assets.
The thing that tracks
the best overall--
tracks dark savings
overall, the best--
is financial.
And you can see in
most of these diagrams,
the black dotted lines are
close to the solid black line.
So financial assets increase
when savings is positive,
but these other real
and physical stuff
as well as gifts play a role.
Gifts are not trivial
in these economies,
as you already know from
thinking about insurance and so
on.
So all these things add up.
Gifts, financial
transfers, inventory,
and so on add up to savings.
But gifts could be negative,
because they're not incoming,
but they're outgoing.
They're not saving it.
They're giving it away.
It's not always negative.
Gifts are positive,
in some instances.
But in any event, they're not
a trivial order of magnitude,
and we will look at
that subsequently again.
In terms of financial
flows, you've
got something called
the current account.
For the US, for example, are
they running a trade balance,
or are they earning
money from abroad?
And likewise, for
these villages,
they export and import stuff.
We take the trade balance as
the difference if positive.
Exports exceed imports.
And likewise, some
member of the household
is in Bangkok and earning
money and sending that money
back home as a gift, that's
factor income earned abroad.
In China, people work
in the Philippines
and send money back home.
So this is called
the current account.
Now, there are corresponding
items, offsetting items,
on the financial account.
Basically, if you're
running a trade surplus,
you're acquiring
claims on foreigners,
which could be by
holding their currency,
holding their financial assets,
or holding their real assets.
And as we'll talk
about next time,
the US has been
running a trade deficit
with China, which means China
is acquiring claims on the US,
holding US treasuries,
real estate, and so on.
So the names change to
protect the innocent,
in the sense of we're not
looking at countries here.
We're looking at villages, but
we're doing all the accounting
for the villages
the way it's done
for countries, with exactly
the same accounting identities.
And the point of all of
this is only to tell you
where some of these things
that you've heard of
are coming from.
From the ground up, from
each and every household,
we have the financial
accounts-- income statement,
balance sheet, and so on.
We can add it up over all
households in the village,
as the sample allows, and get
the village-level aggregates.
This is for all of Thailand.
Thailand was running
a trade deficit,
and foreigners were
acquiring claims on Thailand
until the 1997 financial crisis,
in which case, things reversed.
And they've been a bit
unstable ever since.
In this case,
balance of payments
are roughly a certain
of GDP, maybe 10%.
That's a big number.
It's typically 5%.
So when we come to
villages, you might ask,
how big are these flows?
And the answer is,
typically, much bigger.
For example, in Chachoengsao,
the balance of payments,
including the trade and
the current account,
can be as high as 20% of GDP.
And Lopburi, likewise
reaches 15% of GDP.
So they are small
open economies.
These villages are engaged
with the rest of the country.
And in fact, we
can break that down
into the gifts, which I
showed you a moment ago,
as well as, here, the
measure of openness
in terms of trade, which
is exports minus imports.
So roughly, Chachoengsao
near Bangkok, its imports
and exports are almost
matching one another.
Whereas, out in the
Northeast, the imports
are a lot bigger
than the exports.
The imports are for production.
They're inputs acquired
for production,
and they export a little
bit of their output.
They eat a lot of the rice that
they produce and export less.
I'm getting ready to
show you the model.
One, what about
the relative price?
At the beginning
of this class, we
talked about the price of
good 1 the price of good 2.
We have two sectors for
simplicity, agriculture
and manufacturing.
So from the data, we can
actually see, overall,
that the price of the
agricultural good is going up,
the ratio is going down,
from the standpoint
of a typical village, with
the possibility of imports
and exports, just the way we
had countries possibly exporting
and importing to each other.
In terms of the factor prices,
remember the minimized cost
curve?
Well, this is over time.
So we can see the wage
rate and the interest rate,
both adjusted to be in
units of consumption.
Hence, real values
as a numerator.
So in the areas near Bangkok,
the blue and the red,
we can see that wages
tend to be higher
than they are in the Northeast.
Now, near Bangkok,
you would think
this is relatively
capital-abundant,
because they're pretty
industrialized and short
of labor.
So indeed, the relative
price of labor to capital
is higher in the
areas near Bangkok,
reflecting the capital abundance
and the relative shortage
of labor.
The reverse is true
in the Northeast.
And also, we can look at
the interest rate, which
is like the price of capital.
And again, you can see that
now the blue and the red
are at the bottom, because
places near Bangkok
are capital-abundant.
And so the interest
rates tend to be low.
We did this experiment for
the Heckscher-Ohlin model.
Countries that are relatively
abundant in a factor
should be exporting the
good which uses that factor
relatively intensively.
So you can imagine that
places near Bangkok
that are abundant in
capital will have a tendency
to export the
manufactured goods,
because that's the one
that's intensive in capital.
What am I doing today?
I'm just getting the labels to
be realistic in actual context,
realistic relative to last time.
We learned the theory first.
Now we're applying it, although
with some modifications.
The other thing you can
see here is the interest
rates are converging.
They're getting really close
to one another over time.
So one imagines that if
they could [INAUDIBLE]
trade in inputs.
Not just outputs.
It's pretty easy to do
that with a capital input.
But the wage rates
are not converging,
so that's also a hint
that, like the 2x2 model,
we're not going to allow labor
to be moving across borders.
OK, so I'm going to show you the
ingredients for a small open,
economy and then I'm
going to tell you
what the difference is with a
2x2x2 that we did last time.
So it is 2x2--
2 goods, 2 factors--
although it's a village relative
to the rest of the country.
Different from last
time, we're going
to have financial frictions,
like those borrowing-to-wealth
ratios.
There's a lot of
agents in each village,
and they differ in their
wealth and ability levels.
They can choose to be workers
or they could become a firm.
And if they're an
entrepreneur, they
could be in the manufacturing
or agricultural sector.
So that's one of the two 2s--
two goods, agriculture and
manufacturing, two inputs,
capital and labor, with the
factor intensities different.
Labor is owned by households
and supplied inelastically,
like it was last time.
They get this wage w.
Wealth is owned by households
and supplied at an interest
rate, but it's also
changing over time.
Unlike what we had
last time, we've
got dynamics in a way
to save money over time.
They can use their capital,
or they can lend it out.
So we have a borrowing
and lending market,
but that capital
market is imperfect.
Namely, you can't necessarily
use an unlimited amount
of capital k.
You're bounded by your wealth.
So that, for the
third time today,
is mention of the limited
liability constraints.
So the differences
with last time,
we have decreasing
returns to scale,
whereas, last time,
in the theory lecture,
we used and abused
the fact that it
was constant returns to scale--
hence, unit costs
of production, which
scale up and down depending
on the level of production.
Factor mobility is
somewhat limited here,
but the capital good moves
around, unlike last time.
We have financial variables
here and real variables,
whereas, last time, we
only had real variables.
And likewise, here, we
have borrowing constraints.
And last time, we
didn't have any of that.
But this model does have
the different endowments
of the factors.
It does have the different
factor intensities.
It keeps the 2x2x2--
well, 2x2 anyway with
small open economy.
And so part of what you're
going to see in the simulations
reflects what we
learned last time.
And part of it is
a bit different,
because it has a few
additional realistic features.
Rather than take you
through the entire model,
I'll just give you the
notation at the beginning.
Each entrepreneur
can produce sector a,
which could be agriculture,
but it's also manufacturing.
A household has a certain talent
level z and an initial capital
stock.
It will use its inputs,
capital and higher labor,
at its productivity
level, selling it
for the price of output.
But it has to pay input
costs for capital and labor,
and the input
prices are r and w.
So you've seen this many times.
This is just a statement
of profits for a firm.
It happens to be a firm
owned and entirely operated
by a given household, because
the theta ij equals 1.
And here's the
borrowing constraint.
Capital utilized is limited
by the pre-existing stock
of fixed assets
[INAUDIBLE] this constant c
could be greater
than 1, which allows
them to borrow, to acquire fixed
assets and production greater
than what they already own.
Labor is non-negative.
As in that paper with
Anna Palson and Karaivanov
they could choose to be a wage
earner, put all their wealth--
lend it out, basically,
earn interest on it,
or they earn money from
being a wage earner.
Likewise, we have profits
for agriculturalists
and manufacturers.
And they're, in principle,
lending stuff out,
but they could be
borrowing some of it
back to finance production.
And then we have a
utility over consumption
of agriculture and
manufactured goods, which
looks this Cobb-Douglas thing,
where these etas are cleverly
chosen to allow us to talk
about aggregate savings.
Because, in fact,
there's capital
in manufacturing and
capital in agriculture,
and we don't want to
keep having to refer
to the distinction about
where they're saving.
So we come up with
this ideal price index.
Don't worry about it too much.
It exists.
That's all we need to know.
OK, it's a small open economy.
Households have their
capital endowment.
We fit a distribution
that fits pretty well,
relative to the histograms
I've already shown you.
We have the labor endowments.
We know how much time they have.
We give them a
little bit of sleep
and come up with how
many units of labor
they can supply over the year,
which is fixed and exogenous.
Then they have a savings rate.
Which, again, as I already
said, that was an omega.
We fit to match the data.
I mentioned that, in the
context of the cash holdings,
one could imagine having
these households solve
discounted expected
utility maximization
problems over
their lifetime that
adds a lot to the complication.
So instead of doing that,
we just basically impose
from the data onto
the households
an estimated savings rate.
Now, this is a kind of
interesting diagram,
because all these parameters,
like the factor intensity
numbers and everything
else, are going
to be calibrated, which I'll
tell you about momentarily.
And we will generate
pictures like this.
So I mentioned the
calibration, only because you
can draw any picture you want.
But this is what it's going
to look like after the work is
done of estimation.
Over here, we have
low-wealth households
versus high-wealth households.
The other dimension
of heterogeneity
is low talent
versus high talent.
And you can see if
they're not very talented,
they're not going to go into
either type of business.
They're going to be workers.
On the other hand, if talent
reaches a higher level,
they could decide to go into
manufacturing or agriculture.
And then for a given
level of wealth,
they may be constrained
or unconstrained.
Ironically, the more
talented they are,
given a certain borrowing
constraint and their wealth,
the more constrained
they're going to be,
because they would
like to do more
and they're not
allowed to do it.
And here, it actually
moves from being
constrained in
manufacturing to being
constrained in agriculture.
So it's the really,
really talented guys
who are sticking on the farm,
given the parameters that we
estimated.
This I've already said.
We're going to have an
open market for capital,
but a closed market for labor.
And again, that's because the
interest rates are converging.
So it looks like, in
the end, at least,
capital can be moved across
provinces without a cost.
Here's, finally, the
calibration slide.
We have to figure out
the relative prices.
We need the interest rate.
We're going to take
it as exogenous.
The relative price
of manufacturing
versus agriculture we're
going to take as exogenous
and match it up with what we
see in the data as exogenous.
I'll come back to how
we pick it in a minute.
And the borrowing
rates are exogenous.
We stick in, for
the interest rate,
what we observe in the data.
We don't know about this
relative price of the borrowing
limit, but we do have the
profit sharing in each sector.
So we move the relative prices
to match the profit share.
So for example, if
agriculture has a price pa
and we observe a large
relative share of profits
from agriculture,
then we imagine
that it's a relatively high
price of the agricultural goods
relative to the manufacturing
goods and vice versa.
Likewise, we're going to move
the borrowing limit to match
the observed wage rate.
The point being that if
they can't borrow very much,
they're not going to have a
very high scale of production.
They're not going to
hire a lot of labor.
The demand for labor
being low means
the wage that has to
clear the local market
is going to be low.
The bigger picture
here is calibration.
You have objects that
matter a lot in the model.
And how you pick
them, well, here, we
pick them by taking
the data that we have
and varying the parameters
in the model in such a way
that we can fit the
model-generated data
to the actual data.
Doing that, we have
to make a choice
of which part of the
actual data to use
to calibrate which parameter.
And again, read
the Dawkins thing,
and you'll see a discussion
of this much more generally.
OK, so let's look
at what happens.
How well are we doing?
Oh, these economists, they
come up with these models.
God knows how well
they predict, so I'll
show you how well we're doing.
This is, at the calibrated
values for Lopburi, I believe--
doesn't say that on the slide--
the actual level of output and
the predicted level of output--
model-predicted.
So we ran a
successful experiment.
If you think about the
model as an experiment,
populated by the
parameters we calibrate,
then we are able to take this
stylized model, a la Lucas,
and use it to interpret reality.
This is pretty close
for consumption,
the actual being
below the model.
So in this case, they're
consuming a little bit less
than what the model
says they might,
despite our attempt
to fit it to the data.
And this is for assets,
which is very, very close.
Now, these last
three figures are all
aggregated across all the
households in a given economy.
OK, so having sort of--
oh, and this is
cash holdings, which
is one of our weak points.
And we're pretty
close for a while,
and then cash
holdings in the data
still want to be higher
than in the model.
God knows why they
want that cash.
We're just still dumbfounded.
That's the way they're saving
over time, in the aggregate.
Accumulating claims
on foreigners?
Yeah, that's the paper currency.
It's a claim on the central
bank, and they love.
It doesn't bear
interest or anything.
But anyway, I'll
stop complaining.
OK, so having done pretty
well with the aggregates,
one hopes we've earned
the right to talk
about individual experiences.
Now, needless to say, there are
many households in a village
and a non-trivial number of
households in the sample.
We're fitting the
aggregates via calibration.
I wouldn't expect
perfect performance
for each and every individual.
That's too much to hope
for, but let me show you
how well we did
with household a,
that labor household
in Lopburi that we
featured at the beginning.
So this is the actual
darker line, labor income.
I showed you this path
before, actually, in wages.
And they went into
livestock a bit.
They went into business
and borrowed to do it.
This is the actual
model prediction,
which is a lot flatter,
but it's not that far off.
It matches pretty well at
the beginning and the end.
This is consumption,
which is horrible.
So for this household,
the actual numbers drop
lower than what the model
says it ought to be,
and fixed assets is closer.
We do pretty well
with fixed assets,
including at the individual
household a level.
And cash, again, under and over,
going up, though, for both.
OK, so I'm tempted to put
this in the US context,
because it may make it
seem more real if you
haven't been in Thai villages.
What's the effect on farmers
of restricted exports to China,
when China retaliated?
They came to an agreement,
but, still, China's
not purchasing as much.
The other way around, what
about manufactured goods
coming in from China?
What's the effect
on wage-earners
that produce the thing, which
is now being imported, whereas,
before, had been
produced domestically?
But we're going to talk
about those things next time,
but we can already
answer questions
like this for Thailand.
If, for example, we take
the actual estimated model
and run counterfactuals, OK?
So suppose we impose trade
frictions within the country.
What are tariffs going
to do, basically?
They hurt trade.
So if a village
had been exporting
a lot of agricultural goods and
importing a lot of manufactured
goods, as in the Northeast, then
the effect of a trade friction
will increase the
price of the thing
that they have been
buying, the import good,
and decrease the price
of the export good.
Hurt both ways.
We're going to do it by 1%.
So we're going to take
these calibrated prices that
were used to match the
payments to factors and profits
and now vary them
and see what happens.
We're also going to do
a financial experiment
in the model.
We're going to change
the interest rate.
So it's like we're going
to impede financial flows.
So again, the effect
of it always hurts.
So if the village had been
a net lender, for example,
then the effect of
the financial friction
is to make the
interest rate lower,
because lenders don't
like low interest rates.
We talked about that when we did
the lecture on income and price
effects for households
in the two-good world.
Anyway, so if they're
lending, they're
not going to it that the
interest rate goes down.
And likewise, if they
had been borrowing,
we would have gone
the other way and make
the loans more expensive.
So that's the effect of the
way we capture in the model,
in order to run an experiment,
the impact of trade frictions
through tariffs and/or
internal frictions
and financial frictions.
So now you want to
see what happens.
This is in Lopburi,
and this is the effect
of that 1% increase
in trade frictions,
making exports
give less revenue.
Imports now cost more.
That's going to affect
the production and profits
from the manufactured good
and the agricultural good.
And in turn, remember the
algorithm from last time
that I reviewed?
Those price changes
are going to map into--
input quantities are going to
map into relative factor price
movements, OK?
But there's a lot of
diversity in these economies.
As I've been saying, households
differ by their initial level
of capital.
They differ also
by their talent.
So we have capital moving on
the x-axis and the average skill
level, pretty high skill level,
and very high skill level.
And then what's getting plotted
here is the gains or losses.
So it's a tariff, effectively.
So you might expect losses.
And in fact, these average
or low skilled guys
do suffer losses, arguably
because they're wage earners,
although you can see that.
And the movement in
production from the capital
good and the
labor-intensive good
was such as to hurt the wage.
So remember, we did
Stolper-Samuelson,
where an increase
in the price causes
an increase in the
factor price of the good
that is used
relatively intensively.
So despite all the differences
with the 2x2 from last time,
that ingredient is
playing a role here.
So these wage-earners
are hurt, initially.
But then, ironically, as we
move in the cross section
for a higher level
of capital, they
were actually producers,
not wage-earners.
And now the lower
wage helps them,
because it's a lowered
cost of production.
So their profits go up.
Now they're winning, by
a little less than 1%.
And if they're really,
really talented,
they'd been producing at
a higher scale all along,
so the drop in wages is
even better for them.
OK, I'm trying to give
you some intuition here,
but I decided, because
time was short,
I wouldn't be able to actually
prove all these assertions.
I'm just asking you to
imagine, from the 2x2x2
that we did last
time, why it is we're
seeing all this diversity here.
The order of magnitude
is, like, less than 1%.
Here, it's 1%.
So that's pretty small.
But if you look at the
financial frictions in Lopburi,
in the sense that I described,
you can see bigger numbers.
First of all, you see
winners and losers.
You also see that it matters
whether they were wage-earners
or capitalists.
But above all, you see that the
high-skilled guys can benefit
up to 10% from the increase
in the interest rate
that's associated with
the financial friction,
because the village
had been borrowing,
but some of those
guys don't borrow.
They lend.
And likewise, there
are other people here,
the average-skilled
guys, who are
taking big losses of up to 10%.
So again, one could imagine
producing pictures like this.
And if we go back
to household a, what
happens to a wage
earner in the US
with manufactured imports
or a farmer in the Midwest
with agricultural exports?
What happens in Lopburi to that
wage-earner under the trade
friction or under the
financial friction?
They lose.
He or she loses.
That household loses.
So we validated the model to
try to make this realistic.
It fit pretty well--
very well.
At the aggregate level,
it fit pretty well.
At the individual level--
so if for some reason
the Thai government
had run this experiment or
they had political issues that
made the country
more isolated, you
could see the effect of that
on individual households
through the lens of the model.
OK, any final questions?
So again, we'll kind
of do it all over again
when we come to the US
next time, next Thursday.